all right if you guys watch the show you
know I'm not being on reality TV but
finally there's a reality show I can get
behind
there is a new show called the sex pack
there and this is where people are gonna
try to become porn stars and they've
just announced their cast let's take a
look at the 2014 ABN Awards Show in Las
Vegas some of porins biggest stars came
together to create a reality competition
called with a sex factor eight guys and
eight girls will compete for porn
stardom and a $1,000,000 prize these 16
contestants have never been seen on film
before an America will vote to decide a
male in a few okay so among some of the
contestants are Wall Street intern Paige
Jennings also Duke University points are
Belle Knox she was gonna be the host but
then she dropped out and has been
replaced by ASA acara so there's the
cast members right there and these all
want to be the next big porn stars did
you guys not try out for this I thought
maybe I was gonna see you guys in the
most fun part about about you know maybe
and when I submitted my tape on VHS and
a CD so you get to you get to have these
fun poor names you to come up with
something right yeah I mean Long John
Silver I mean this is a you get to just
cope with anything I think the front
dong yeah if you got put like a captain
head on or something yeah but like the
guy the front seemed very excited and it
seems like that's the energy of it but
then you wonder if dreams are gonna be
crushed say the person who wins it'll be
like I didn't know the sex industry was
sexy yeah here's my question
when did porn get so hard to get into it
seems like you just show up like I
didn't really you know like American
Idol the voice like you're trying to get
this record contract or you know it's a
bit it's a tough industry to break into
porn is you know there's there's some
fetish out there that you fit already
right you know whatever you look like
there's somebody who would hire you not
for not much and frankly most porn now I
think is being made by people on their
phones and uploaded to the internet
anyway so it's like why is there a
reality show for an industry that
anybody can get into already
that's a like basically if you have a
webcam you're already halfway into the
porn industry in the first place so
you're already there I have to say I
kind of dig this one because it's people
that want to do something and I hate
reality TV as a general theme but like
shark tank
I love shark tank you're watching people
that are passionate about the country
and trying to get it to the next level
if these people are passionate about
[ __ ] why don't have America's next
plumber's assistant like [ __ ] call a
plumber and become his assistant it's
not that hard
you don't have to have a reality show to
do it that's how stupid most reality
except the winning prize is not gonna be
one thing though okay yeah Brandon our
twenty dollars an hour could be like a
golden plumber a golden plunger or
something like that why do people people
keep tuning into television for sex I
mean we did another sex story earlier
but like that's the part that I don't
get like we did saying on the sex box a
couple weeks ago which is a UK show
where people literally have sex in a box
but there's no camera on them while
they're in the box they just then come
out of the box and talk about it after
but yet we live in a time when you can
see sex constantly so why it seems like
TV is not quite sure what to do because
they can't wait all right so it actually
made me wonder so okay we know at least
some of you guys know but then there's
reality shows you don't like watching
them much where there's the you know
there's the challenge round and then
there's the prove yourself round they
can't show any of its titillating it's
the idea of it again it's like though
it's like the horror movies that are
most effective when it plays out in your
mind you know this is this shows Ozzy is
gonna be forced to believe things to
your imagination because of the nature
of television right and so we're gonna
just sort of fill in those blanks
ourselves right what I just want the the
teary confessions in the theater view
room that's gonna be always the
highlight
yeah yeah you'll need plenty of tissues
for those
[Music]